what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into guardians of the
galaxy volume three this is basically
Guardians disassembled and this isn't
really like a you know dissolution of
the guardians so much as it's really
more of adding a few numbers to their
ranks now really the most notable
addition to the guardians at this point
you know at the immediate outset is
really like agent venom Flash Thompson
and of course we'll talk about that here
in a minute
um but the idea here is that this is
again kind of Bendis tying into a lot of
applause threads that were basically put
on hold because of the events of
infinity and so again this is really
kind of a good not really a good
jumping-off point but a really good
point to kind of flying back in to the
events post introduction of Angela but
again it's really the idea that JSON of
spartax is still caught on the heels of
his son Peter quill as well as the
Guardians now of course some of this is
due to the fact that the Guardian to
basically staved off an attack by JSON
of spartax but the other half of this is
adjacent in a lot of ways is just a
brutal guy he's a guy that's really one
of these individuals you know who cut
him wants to have the universe or had
the galaxy under his thumb now the funny
thing is that what initially started out
as you know a team-up more or less or
kind of like a Galactic Council between
himself and the Shiar and the Kree and
so on and so forth eventually led to him
basically speaking to them like
underlings and so it was almost as
though he viewed himself as ruler of the
galaxy before he had actually been
elevated to that point and so we'll
actually find out this is effectively
going to work against him he essentially
left before he could you know figure out
what was going on and so because of this
with regards to the Guardians being
attacked Barr is really in a rocket and
AM star-lord being attacked by by JSON
of spartax we again have max Celyn
coming after after Gamora of course
again max illan was the guy we had
talked about in our first Guardians
video who is just one of the bounty
hunters that have been sent after the
Guardians for the purpose of tracking
down Gamora and bringing her to a
particular group now again Gamora is
basically capture something because of
the fact them actually had learned from
his last conflict with her that in truth
when they at first initially fought he
had actually underestimated what she was
capable of and how powerful she was in
terms of just her combat prowess and
various skills and abilities and so on
and so forth so of course where she's
taken captive we basically end up
switching over to Drax the destroyer now
with regards to why it is that flash
Thompson's here will actually cover this
next week when we do the superior venom
storyline but effectively this just came
out of superior spar
in the sense that that dr. octopus as
Peter Parker came into conflict with
Flash Thompson as agent venom which of
course eventually led to two superior
spider-man gaining the Venom symbiote so
of course you know once the story came
to a conclusion Flash Thompson got it
back and then was more or less kind of
made an Avenger not officially but only
in so much as he was basically sent
alongside the Guardians out into space
now again with regards to being paired
up with Drax a destroyer the first idea
here what Bendis really begins to do is
lay the seeds for the planet symbiote
story which is to say the story that
will give us the origin of the Venom
symbiote and the story where all the
members of the guardians of the galaxy
become venom so it's actually really
really cool but of course again this is
dent is really kind of harping on the
idea that people from Earth just don't
understand how big the universe is how
big the galaxy is and all the things
that exist out there and so with Drax
showing up alongside agent venom
immediately you know the local bartender
like just you know this local guy named
crackle is like get that guy out of here
get him and what he's wearing out of
here so the initial indication is that
this guy knows what the Venom symbiote
is he knows what the Venom symbiote it's
about now this is going to be kind of an
important theme coming back later on
because Flash Thompson will actually
come back to this guy later before she's
basically given different arms and all
invincible because of the fact that from
the perspective of Drax the Venom
symbiote won't be enough and again
that's very true when it comes to the
various weapons and the various enemies
that are out there in the galaxy some of
the cause of the fact that on earth the
Venom symbiote is very very dangerous
but because of the fact that so many
people know what the venom study it is
and so many people are able to combat it
a lot of enemies out there know how to
deal with it according and so flash
really needs to have various tools at
his disposal that will allow him to
overcome different threats now all of
this really seems to be a moot point so
but because of the fact that a handful
of soldiers come out of nowhere smash up
jocks a destroyer and then just take off
and so what we end up doing is we
actually end up jumping to all these
different places where the members of
the guardians were taken the first one
is Peter quill who of course has been
taken personally by Jason now the funny
thing about this is Jason effectively
went through and said kill whoever you
have to kill but get my son now
initially it was captivity it was taking
Peter hostage it was holding him in
confines and trying to find a way to
reason with his son and say look this
road to Iran are basically being a space
cowboy is not
effective you are going to be the next
leader of smart axe you have to step
into the role of what it means to be a
king the issue with this is that Peter
looks at his father and says if your
what it means to be the president will
respond tax dear you're not fit to be a
ruler because you're effectively evil
you're a guy that wants to keep the
world under your thumb you are not a
person that I want to follow behind in
truth he very much wants to be the
opposite of his father and so will the
two seem effectively irreconcilable one
is it happening is Jason basically makes
this throwaway comment that the that
where you are here no one knows where
you're at and no one's coming to save
you which switches over to the idea that
Carol Danvers is coming to find him now
in truth Carol Danvers is aware of what
it was it happened in Peter quill but
this actually came by way of Marvel now
with Kelly sue Taconic taking over the
Carol Danvers I guess the Captain Marvel
line of stories the reason why this
matters is because of the fact that with
regards to Kelly see the colleagues run
of Captain Marvel initially the goal was
to basically remove Carol Danvers from
Earth because despite all the things she
done and her role is basically being
Miss Marvel eventually adopted a mantle
of Captain Marvel the idea was to give
her a more prominent role to basically
just kind of throw things at the wall
and see what's stuck and by removing her
from the planet Earth
it basically returned her to the roots
of the Captain Marvel role as it was
originally held by Marvel of the Kree
and so the idea was to basically say hey
look here's who she used to be but she's
Captain Marvel now she's going to play a
more cosmic role than she did before so
again the most reasonable case to make
this or you know to really present this
scenario with Carol Danvers is to throw
her on guardians of the galaxy simply
because by the time this story took
place the movie was already on you knows
already a lot of hype for the movie you
know coming out and so on and so forth
being out and so was a great jumping
point to basically introduce fans to
what this new Carol Danvers was going to
be because there was so much excitement
around buying the new the new guardians
of the galaxy story now with regards to
rocket racoon he's basically taken by
the Kree and the Kree are really just
kind of experimenting on him at the at
the behest of the supreme intelligence
and that's effectively effectively
what's been happening here all these
different members of the Galactic
Council I had basically been given one
member of the guardian of the galaxy
just because of the fact that in their
eyes they all have their own different
motivations for example with the
Brotherhood of the Badoon they were
effectively attacked and almost pushed
to the brink of extinction by Thanos and
so
question is where's Santos give us
Stannis we want his location of course
the best person again it's information
from is it's Gamora and so they
effectively subject her to a series of
endless battles hoping to wear her down
to the point that she can't fight
anymore when it comes to Drax a
destroyer he's taken by the Shiar and so
time and time again it's basically this
idea that somewhere along the line these
different members of the guardians came
into conflict with these members of the
Galactic Council and these members of
the Galactic Council basically get their
own personal revenge against the
individuals the members of the guardians
that specifically harmed them now
jumping back to Flash Thompson to agent
venom remember he's still pretty new to
the Avengers roster he's new to what
they're capable of he's new to what it
is that they're able to pull off and so
while he's trying to basically figure
out where it is the Drax to the story is
I'm taken trying to figure out you know
anybody that can basically help him he
suddenly comes across Captain Britain
and the Valkyrie and you know Hawkeye
and black widow and beast members of the
Avengers and of course they play on this
they play on this idea that hey man you
got to come with us see what had
happened was there was like this giant
civil war back on earth between the
x-men you got to come back you got to
help us get everything sorted out and so
on the surface it seems like a rescue
mission and the way they pass it off
actually works really really well I mean
they basically say hey look like you're
a human being in nowhere you know in
this massive bar out in the middle of
space it was only a matter of time
before you drew the attention all we had
to do just kind of show up here and wait
for people to start talking about how
there's a human and a person with a
Venom symbiote walking around this place
but then of course we basically end up
having the Venom symbiote react
violently to a threat the way it
normally does only for us to realize
these are not the Avengers instead
they're basically Scrolls posing as the
Avengers for the purpose of taking down
Flash Thompson and so where each of
these members of the guardians seemed
almost completely and totally you know
incapacitated and effectively taken out
where's Peter Quill's able to basically
engineer his escape or at least it seems
like he's able to make his getaway now
of course this is only really evident on
the surface in the sense that he's taken
prisoner by the scrolls alongside again
Drax the destroyer who's being held
captive by the Shiar Gamora who's being
forced to fight in these endless battles
against the the Badoon but then suddenly
we have the return of Angela now with
regards to Angela's character again
during the events of infinity she had
basically just kind of been spacefaring
she had left the planet Earth during the
whole event of course all that was
basically written to read
signer character and maintain interest
among fans in terms of Angela as a
concept of course again as we know it
wasn't the most popular thing to have
ever grapes Marvel Comics but the fact
remains here that this is basically
Bendis you know telling us that in terms
of the relationship between between
Gamora and Angela there's still very
much a partnership if anything you know
in the sense of they're still they still
view themselves as warriors and as
warriors still we usually always be
there for one another whenever the time
calls for help in such a fashion now
again at the same time as Peter quill
basically makes his escape from from
Spartacus who basically have Carol
Danvers at rest you know flies in to
rescue him and that kind of thing so
again it's you know it's really agent
venom and it's Carol Danvers who are
effectively being added to the ranks of
the Guardians but of course being
confronted by his father what happens is
Peter quill of course without his father
really you know without a father
realizing what's going on
effectively forces him to admit that he
had called down for the assassination of
his own son some because of the fact
that Peter refused to fall in line with
the traditional role that was assigned
to him as a future leader of spart
absence of this information as is
basically being broadcast out to
everybody who's watching in the sense
that Peter says look you call us
criminals but we're individual standing
up for the greater good we're
individuals standing up for people that
can't help themselves what does that
make you for trying to kill us torture
us that kind of thing for doing that
what it does is it broadcast out to the
supreme intelligence and various other
members of the Galactic Council who
essentially turn their backs on on on
JSON of spartax at the same time the
citizenry of sparked acts who had no
idea what was going on basically call
for the death of Jason and so
essentially he's asked it from his own
Kingdom he's forced out of his own rule
and forced out of his own land and so
what is up happening here is that where
Flash Thompson and venom were
effectively separated from one another
in order to to allow them to basically
maintain control and in order for the
the scrolls to essentially test the
Venom symbiote and see what's going on
again it's this idea that there are
various races out there that know what
the Venom symbiote is about and where
one of the scrolls to try to put on the
Scindia it effectively kills them now
again this really kind of taps into the
idea of how agent venom was being
written at the time in the sense that
the Venom symbiote had no real
communication with flash which is to say
we didn't see with the venom scindia the
kind of thing that we saw in Marvel now
2.0 with reprice in the sense of the
venom
it was talking to Lee and Lee was
talking to the Symbian instead it was
really more of like a psychic bond so to
speak that existed between Flash
Thompson in the Symbian would flash
basically had this kind of empathic link
where he can understand what the Symbian
wanted what its motivations were that
kind of thing and so of course because
of the fact that this scroll is not
deemed a suitable host the Symbian
basically kills them you know in the
sense that the school simply says I
can't control it now again it's
basically Ben is telling us the Flash
Thompson was able to control it again
kind of hearkening to this measure of
communication and where flash read ons
the sim biet the idea is to basically go
on a Tron quest to save the other
members of the guardians of the galaxy
and so again Peter quill Carol Danvers
they're able to make their escape
Jason's effectively ousted Angela F of
stating Gamora as kind of a cool concept
to see these various characters coming
back together again finding Groot
bringing him back into the fold but then
the question becomes what happens with
with venom what happens with you know
with the agent venom character and so
what this is going to do is it's
actually going to lead directly into the
next story which is a planet symbiote
the story that effectively picks up with
this idea that the Venom symbiote itself
is sentient
the venom city itself does have
motivation and it does have Drive and
it's very much going to lay the lay the
foundation and the groundwork for what
we'll actually see in the venom story
from only while different Marvel and
Marvel now of course that story that
we've covered already but if you guys
are new here to come let's explain make
sure you hit the sub button to become
part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you guys in
the next video peace
[Music]
[Applause]